俺の名前は、「怪盗ハジメーン」
世界でも有数の盗み人だ
俺の特技はアンロック
ま、簡単に言えば
スマホのパスワード解除だ
今日のターゲットはこの3人
TETUYA
YOSIMITU(？)
MUSIMEGANE
ミッションは簡単
こいつら3人の誰でもいいから
1人のパスワードを突破する
それだけが、俺に与えられた使命だ
狙いは今しかねぇ
最初のターゲットは、
お前だ
おっと、
やめておこう。
こいつは鋭いな…
あっちのバカにしておくか
M：眠いなぁ
T：あ～みんな眠い状態ってゆのはありかんなぁ
よしっ、なんとかスマホをゲットできたぞ
あいつらはYoutuber、そして頭は悪い
テキトーに000でどうだ！
違ったぞ
111どうだ！
違う！
そうだ、
あいつの本名は小柳津徹也
あいつの本名、0(お)、8(や)、１(い)、2(づ)
違うだとっ！
となると最後、
ターゲットが大好きな下ネタ、どうだ！
(悲しいBGM♪)
いかにバレずにスマホをターゲットに返すかも怪盗のポイント
そう、このように、静かに忍び寄り、
こっそりと置いておく
カメラを踏んづけてしまった…失態
はっはっはっ…
はっはっ…
ラストラストラストラストラストラスト…！
6(む)、4(し)、6(む)、4(し)
ふぁぁっ…くっ…
は：っっし…頑張るか今日も1日
Y：何言われたのー＠＃＄％何やったのww
Y：俺じゃねぇか！！
Y：ぃやっっっはっwwちょっww
Y：あぁそういうことか…
Y：何をしてると思ったら…
は：これが最後のチャンスなんだ…
は：これで解ければ俺の勝ち
Y：考えてみろ
は：10(と)…4(し)3(み)2(つ)
は：5桁か
は：そんな安易なことはないだろう
は：行くぞ
は：なんだと…
は：としみつ誕生日は？
Ｙ：7月17だ…
は：まさかな…
Ｙ：17て言うとる…
ｗｗｗ
は：な…なんだとっ…
Y：これ以上はない
は：「としみ」か
は：「としみ」だろ貴様っ…！
Y：やってみろぉ…
10(と)、4(し)、3(み)
Y：ぅぬおおおおおおおおおお！！
は：あっはっはっはっはwww
~ED~
Y：くっそぉ…
T：なんて簡単なんだ…
は：嘘でしょwww
Y：うん、ないから「としみ」…だよ
は：貴様らに謎が解けるか…
M：いや違うと思うけど、
M：93年の、2月14日生まれ
M：違う…そんなない…パスだ
は：レベルが違う
Y：ありえないっ！
M：どこやったっけなぁ
Y：開けるっ…！
Ｍ：どこにあったけ
T：2がやってないと思う
T：んんん…111か？1ないなぁ
M：全部同じじゃないのが嫌、逆に
おおっ！
は：くっそ…ww